le cadre du cours de géographie il est
souvent demandé aux élèves de localiser
un territoire à partir de leur corps de
mes geôliers à savoir la latitude et la
longitude les élèves s'embrouille
souvent pourtant il s'agit d'un exercice
relativement simple quand on a bien
compris la technique c'est ce que je
vous propose dans cette vidéo
prenons un exemple vous devez localisé à
re manche en france et les coordonnées
géographiques sont 49 degré 20 minutes
nord et 0° 37 minutes ouest alors vous
devez les transformer en degré décimaux
si vous ne savez plus comment faire il y
à une vidéo qui vous expliquent sur blu
geo
comment y arriver et à partir de là on
va retrouver le point sur la carte
c'est très rapide d'abord il faut bien
se mettre en tête la carte est localisé
plus ou moins le point alors je dois me
repérer sur la carte évidemment regardé
les différents
ces légendes et les différents points je
peux retrouver alors ici je vois que le
zéro degré il est là de l'attitude le 2
degrés ouest et l'a donc évidemment je
vais me trouver entre les deux points
puisque moi je suis à 0,37 ou 0,62
suffit si je suis en décimales alors ici
sur la capture d'écran vous ne voyez pas
mais dans votre classe vous verrez bien
que ici on est sur les
50 degrés
nord est ici 48° nord
donc mon point devrait ce logique mans
se trouvait ici quelque part ça c'est
très important de déjà bien localisée
c'est déjà la moitié du chemin qui est
fait alors pour la longitude je vais
mesurer
l'écart entre mes deux méridien je dois
mesure est plus ou moins à l'endroit où
mon point peut se trouvait donc je sais
que c'est plus ou moins ici dans la
bêtise de la baie de la scène donc je
vais mesurer à cet endroit la fois que
j'ai mesuré je me rends compte que j'ai
4 85 cm pour 2 degrés il ya bien deux
degrés de différence donc sur ma carte
2° font cap 85 cm
une fois que je sais ça il est très
facile de calculer les 0,62 qui
m'intéresse attention je dois bien
prendre les degrés décimaux 0,62 ça
équivaut à 1.5 cm pourquoi comment était
je fais mon calcul
j'ai simplement ici divisé en deux et
fait foi 0.62 pour passer de 2 degrés à
0,62 degré et je fais exactement la même
chose de l'autre côté de mon équation
je prends les 4,85 je divise par 2 et je
fais 0.62
passons maintenant à la latitude
je vais faire exactement la même chose
je vais mesurer l'écart entre mes deux
parallèles alors ici c'est plus grands
évidemment pour les besoins de la vidéo
j'ai ici tracé la flèche verte la double
flèche verte un petit peu plus à gauche
mais moi je vous conseille de le faire
vraiment mieux puisque le point il est
logiquement ici quelque part c'est ce
qu'on a vu tout au début on devait plus
ou moins le localiser alors je vais
mesurer et je me rends compte que j'ai
également deux degrés d'écart entre les
deux parallèles et qui font cette fois
ci c'est de 4 cm attention pour
longitude et pour la latitude dans ce
cas ci c'est à chaque fois 2 degrés
d'écart entre les méridiens et les
parallèles
c'est pas toujours le cas il faut bien
regarder sur les cartes évidemment une
fois que j'ai mesuré la distance entre
les deux parallèles
je peux calculer ce qui m'intéresse
qu'est ce qui m'intéresse ici c'est
49,33 à il ya une différence par rapport
à la latitude à la longitude pardon
puisque dans la longitude
ici je partais de zéro et je voulais qu
à savoir 0 62 mais dans ce cas ci le
parallèle qui est ici c'est pas 0 je
vais partir de là pour mesurer
donc qu'est-ce que je vais devoir faire
mais je fais un petit calcul que vous
retrouvez ici
moi je veux connaître 49,33 c'est bien
ça que j'ai ici et je vais soustraire
bien la valeur de mon parallèle de
référence à partir duquel je vais
mesurer
aidons dans ce cas si j'obtiens 1,33
degrés il ya 1,3 degrés d'écart entre
mon poing et le parallèle qui va me
servir pour mesurer donc je fais mon
petit calcul je dois passer de 2 à 1,33
je vais divisé par deux et faire foi
1,33 je fais la même chose pour l'autre
terme de mon équation ya rien de
compliqué et j'obtiens donc la distance
donc s'il faut retenir ici c'est d'un
côté j'ai 1.5 cm et de loot j'ai 89 cm
eh bien je n'ai plus qu'à mesurer et
donc la j'obtiens le point qui est ici
je peux vais faire une chose une carte
c'est bien là que se situe à re manche
j'ai réussi à localiser celui j'espère
que cette vidéo vous a été utile qu'elle
vous a aidé à comprendre cette petite
technique
si vous avez des questions les
commentaires ont pas votre disposition
n'oubliez pas le comble si vous avez
apprécié ça permet de faire long de la
chaîne et de partager cette ressource à
d'autres élèves qui sont éventuellement
en difficulté
je vous souhaite un bon travail et à
très bientôt
[Musique]